he probably is definitely the worst
president of my lifetime
uh he may be the worst president ever
I'm trying to think of a president that
hurt this country more than him in a
short period of time
got people killed because of his
incompetence like Afghanistan those
people would accomplished would have
just been Trump who would have said no
to taking out the troops uh before this
almost any sane person would do that how
about leaving uh 45 billion dollars
worth of lethal arms behind epigram
air base in a country dominated by
terrorists who you know are going to use
them to kill your kill your own people
which they have done
that that decision can only be made by a
traitor or a Madman
I mean the guy has been a terrible
president